[Musique]
ce jeudi 29 août ses élèves du collège
titan au port visite est exploitation
des hauts de saint paul
ils apprennent ici les modes de
production de la filière biologique une
filière en pleine expansion la réunion
plus de 300 exploitations sont
aujourd'hui certifiées en agriculture
biologique
le département soutient cette filière en
proposant ses produits dans la
restauration scolaire des collèges nos
départements nous avons des collèges qui
utilisent ses produits
22h ont signé des conventions bientôt il
y en aura plus on va passer à 30 et le
but c'est qu'à terme l'ensemble des
collèges puissent s'approvisionner en
produits pays en produits bio sur le
marché local grâce aux agriculteurs de
la réunion après le chant direction les
cuisines du collège titans ou
aujourd'hui et proposer un menu
spécialement composée de produits
biologiques une action mise en place
dans le cadre de la troisième édition du
plan nutrition santé au sein de ce
collège
les aliments lait bio de bons pour la
santé tandis que les autres il y a les
pesticides
de chimie plus à la fin mars ou est ce
que eux ils ont pu produit a donc rallié
visiter quelques carottes choux un peu
de courgettes
on a aussi pas mal de citrouilles et
chouchou essentiellement et quelques
oeufs vont nous produire le département
s'engage à favoriser l'utilisation des
produits locaux en restauration
collective
un engagement qui prépare la prochaine
réglementation qui préconise que d'ici
20% des aliments préparés dans la
restauration scolaire soit issu de
l'agriculture biologique
[Musique]